what did you marinate this steak because  it's Howard as well you killing me with  thumbs out ah it's a family secret oh  come on you gotta tell me that what's  the secret come on you could do it that  is one of the best goddamn steaks I ever  had in my life ever what solicitor  what's the fact was the family secret  recipe it's greg has ground garlic a  little bit of soy that's it yeah that's  it doesn't I felt it was a family secret  su recipe no no you said to me this is a  family secret and you gave it up the  maple just like that useful the secret  family recipe today maybe useful a  little some about me tomorrow  I was just saying that you would just  saying just saying gets people sent away  just sayin got me a nine-year stretch  and Alcatraz you understand so just  sayin  could get you buried real quick look at  this face